erdogan has won re-election in a first
ever second round of turkey's
presidential election on Sunday
s his run as turkey's longest serving
leader he will serve for another
five-year term after facing down one of
his most difficult re-election
Challenges ever defeating his main
opponent kamalika Sterling with the
leader of the Turkish opposition
so for erdogan he's been in power for 20
years already and now he's going to
continue that run
his biggest problem going forward is
going to be Turkey's economy that has a
critical shortage of foreign currency
that has rapid inflation and that has
Western investors and governments kind
of scaling back their exposure to the
Turkish lira he has a very unorthodox
sense of Economic Policy where his goal
he says is to grow the economy basically
at any cost he has pressured the Central
Bank into cutting interest rates in
spite of turkey's High rate of inflation
that's caused a currency crisis over the
last couple of years and that's
something that he and his government are
going to have to wrestle with in the
coming months and years
in terms of turkey's role in the world
erdogan has cemented his place as one of
the kind of geopolitical linchpins in a
number of different crises including
Russia's invasion of Ukraine NATO
expansion he brokered a deal between
Russia and Ukraine to unblock a lot of
Ukraine's vital grain exports which
brought down Global food prices last
year you also have the issue of Sweden's
entrance to Nato which is currently
blocked by erdogan who is holding it up
over concerns about what he says are
members of the pkk a terrorist
organization that are he says based in
in Sweden it's a big question going into
the upcoming NATO Summit in Lithuania in
July
this election was erdogan's most
difficult electoral test in years he
faced for the first time a United
opposition that included nationalists
islamists Kurds the traditional
opposition all in one Coalition what
erdogan has done is he's really proven
his appeal to a broad base of Voters in
Turkey who see him as a source of
stability who trust in his leadership to
fix the economy and really be a steady
hand to steer turkey through this series
of crises that it's in right now
foreign